hello everyone and welcome to round six
of the Gibraltar Masters 2020 it's a
young pregnant versus Veselin Topalov
and it's quite the game now the Tata
Steel has ended so we're only joining
into the Gibraltar chest festival in
round six but I will go through your
hashtag suggestions if any of you
suggested any nice games from the
previous rounds I will also try at the
cover as many of them now this game I
was suggested to me a lot like it it's
like I woke up in the morning I opened
the door and there was like a little
note it said dude you know cover
progress game it didn't happen like that
but I just wanted to illustrate how much
you guys suggested it and of course as
always for very good reasons now it
features the French defense again it's
not the only reason I'm showing this but
it is one of the reasons of course as
always now a dude who nice photo sir to
the left of Prague went top all of our
accuracy of Nicky Riga official
photographer of the Gibraltar Gibraltar
Masters 2020 so now we get to enjoy
those as well now without further ado
let's check out the game Prague opens
with E for we have e 6x2 palapa so the
French defense with d4 d5 and Knight to
c3
we have Knight to f6 and now II five
attacking the knight Knight F to d7 and
now F for strengthening in the center as
c5 of course it is coming so c5
attacking the d4 point Knight of three
and developing while defending Bishop to
e7 and now Bishop to e3 by problem with
base B 6 by top all of Enda now Queen to
d2 we have nice to see six most often
you will see castles here but the pole
goes for for a bit of a different move
order we have Knight to c6 Bishop to e2
and only now top all of castles we have
castles by Prague and here the the
general theory of today is that
f5 and Bishop the b7 are are the
seemingly best moves here but the power
goes for C characters on d4 which is a
much rarer line and ok Prabhu I have to
recapture Knight character son
before we have night captures Bishop
captures end here night back to be a now
that the night is no longer useful here
you can shift it over to the c6 we had a
night back to be eight by topalov and
now in expectance of Knight to c6 Prager
goes back the ship back to f2 and here
there is a one game where Knight the c6
was played but here a top olive instead
goes for Bishop to a6 and it's I haven't
seen an interview after the game I'm
pretty sure an interview was given so if
any of you have seen it you know do shed
some light on the whole matter I don't
know who was prepared up until what
point but it's already things are
becoming very interesting here
so here progresses okay I'm gonna trade
Bishop captures Knight captures and now
f5 this is a pretty pretty common
breakthrough in against the French
defense this f5 move and now topple
decides to break the tension with each
captures on f5 which is a bit odd you
could go from Knight to c7 which
strengthens the d5 pawn now you are
actually threatening to capture this but
Apollo says nope it's located to do it
right away and okay we have Knight
captures and d5 by Prabhu and now again
top of could continue simply developing
with rook to e8 but he was for this
tricky nice to be for move which is
tricky of course you cannot capture
because the Queen would be hanging on d2
and of course you cannot capture with
the Queen because the bishop guards the
night so here probably just defense the
knight on d5 we have c4 and now look the
c8 putting pressure on the c4 pawn and
now a3 pushing the knight back with
Knight back to c6 now attacking the e5
pawn and Praga defends that look after a
1 and here at Apollo went for Bishop to
c5 to offer a trade of bishops this way
he could also play Bishop to h4 c just
go after the trade you know via the
Kings side and then after g3 Bishop g5
pushes back the Queen also a possibility
but the paul decided for Bishop to c5
and he allows probably this very nice
expansion with b4 and ok with Bishop
captures
Queen captures now pressuring the DF
pawn and now Queen d7 defending and now
shifting the Queen over to the king side
with Queen to h4 and already you can see
that the black is beginning to feel the
pressure not much you can do with your
rooks the knight really not doing all
the degrade this Knight is a monster
here on d5 there are already ideas over
rook lifts coming in with with some nice
attack so here top allah has to really
decide what to do best for top olive is
something like king to h8 and after King
h8 now you will get a rook a d1 then
Queens the e6 getting out of the way and
after Knight to f4 attacking the Queen
now Queen e7 but if you go if you go
into this then you will allow the rook
to go for this very nice rook lift and
the knight is under attack and the pawn
however there is a route captaincy for
rook captures rook captures and rook
captures here and you get this position
where the material is equal but the
white does have the two against one on
the Queen side which it's hard to say
probably black can hold this but the top
Allah doesn't like it he he's not that
kind of a player so instead after Queen
to h4 to power plays Queen to d8 he
offers a queen trade but but this losses
terribly so feel free to pause the video
and try to find why this lose is
terribly while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations and
finding a move that really really
destroys black and for those who just
want to enjoy the show
it's Knight to f6 check and now this
isn't an offer you have to accept it
because if you move the King Queen
captures and h7 is just made so that's
not possible the palette captured the
night and now Pro goes for not it
captures an f6 that's that's a bad idea
you don't have Queen g5 check fall by
made because of Queen to d4 check
forcing a queen trade so this would be
actually just throwing away the game
after you've sacrificed a piece for a
winning in a for a winning game so after
Knight to f6 check G captures an f6 we
have first rook
a to d1 not allowing Queen to d4 and now
the ball has to decide can I can I move
the Queen
play something else a problem is if you
move the Queen and they really aren't
all that many squares where you can do
so
Queen to c7 now you get it captures an
f6 with the threat of mate
so kink the a treat now getting ready to
bring the rook over to g8 but now rook
d3 and here it's a it's amazing but
everything wins for white there is the
simple threat of just well getting
checkmated also Queen to h6 fallback
Queen g7 mate they still an idea so you
could try rook c8 going for this rook
captures anyone but just Queen rook
captures rook after same Queen to h6 is
sufficient and now there's not much you
can do here if rook to g8 and then just
a rook to h3 again completely winning if
you decide to go for checking f2 and the
next move whatever black plays it's it's
checkmate well unless you want to start
throwing away pieces but you are getting
checkmated so after locate the d1 top
off says okay I don't have a move here
I'm gonna play Knight captures on e5 and
give up my queen
at least the try and survive the attack
so rook captures on the 8th of course
progress up the Queen sacrifice route
chapters on f8 and now Queen captures on
f6 threatening the night here
Knight to g6 and now h4 you are
threatening of course h5 h6 and Queen g7
mate so the topple has to prevent this
with h5 and now rook the f1 preparing to
win the pawn here put pressure on f7 so
f4 and now once again feel free to pause
the video and try to find the quickest
way to victory while I'll give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
and finding such such a beautiful
breakthrough and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's g4 and
here again the threat is the same
captures on h5 h6 Queen g7 mate so you
could try to eliminate the point if you
eliminated with this point in just h5
and it's pretty much the same thing if
you try to gain some sort of a perpetual
here it doesn't really work you can just
capture the night and now it's not a
problem
Ruby g3 checking if to rock f3 check
you're gonna move and yes you will have
to survive
few checks but after that not much you
can do here this is this is a threat so
let's say Ruka fate but now captures
captures and you you have a queen
against the rook of course this is
completely winning so after G 4 you
could try F captures and G 3 I'm Poisson
but then you just get Queen captures and
f7 with chair King h8 and Queen captures
in g6 again this is a game over so here
after G 4 top all tried the immediate
rook to d3 but now we have G captures on
h5 we have rook to g3 check and now
comes King f2 and now again top olive
could try to save the night with
something like night to f8 but it's it's
it will just be pointless rook e1
followed by rook to e7 is coming and you
don't again have all that many moves
let's say rook captures on c4 you can
try to check the White King for a little
bit but still rookie 7 and it's not not
hard to calculate that the king will be
able to escape King if one if rook c1
check you just go King EE two rules you
to check and now you start marching the
king of the board the rook do you want
check you're gonna go King C for Roxy to
check you're gonna go king b5 Rho VD v
now finally king a6 and the that's all
there is for for the black rooks and
then next is the game over just Queen
captures on f7 so after this King F to
move the Paul says okay no point in
trying to save it the night let's just
go for Knight captures on h4 and now
what do you do here again it's not
enough that you have this rook to g2
check even if h6 is played it's
perfectly perfectly enough but progress
okay I'm just gonna capture the knight
now all I have to do is basically trade
off one of the rooks and then it's
pointless for black to continue so to
power plays rook captures on c4 and here
probably played rook to e1 and it was in
this position almost 33 that Veselin
Topalov resigned the game and a
brilliant 33 move victory against the
French defense by a young pregnant nun
de
there's really nothing to do here you
can give one check and then after rookie
to that's that's pretty much all there
is if you trade your rook against the
Queen if you go back still just the
Queen captures here attacks the rook
crew goes back and still rook to e7
there's nothing nothing
to do here a hh6 is coming there's
constant pressure on f7 and well it's
just a pointless pointless game for
black but okay after rook to e1 T'Pol
resigned and like I said a brilliant
victory bye-bye entrepreneur Nanda and
it's amazing how how a player liked
Apollo it's probably because he's a
player like the Paul - Paul himself that
he just since he's so he's so tactically
aware that he just doesn't think that he
can get himself in a position where I
move like Knight to f6 will be possible
after his Queen to d8 move he just
doesn't think that this works against
him because he's the wizard he's the
attacker he's the one that creates stuff
it's easy to you know I think you're
you're impervious to just you know such
such tactics and just night if six wins
the game it's incredible stuff but but
it happens so yeah after around six
Prague way is currently seventh with
with five out of six points that's
pretty pretty amazing stuff only one
player on five-and-a-half out of six
that's under AC panco
so like I said I will be checking out on
your hashtag suggestions to see some of
the games from previous rounds that I've
heard mommy ro had a very nice game and
some other players also had a pretty
some pretty good game so I will check
that out and yeah I also wanted to
mention it's never easy playing the
French defense it's it's much easier to
attack the French then the defending
with the French but there is a one
excellent game where the French defense
was played if you if you haven't seen
the game to check it out I will put a
link to it in the description below it
will be the first thing you will see
automated Kawachi which defeated Bobby
Fischer with the French defense so if
you still haven't seen that game - check
it out it's really really just a
masterclass and it's it's in the period
where where Bobby just didn't lose any
games so prior to that I believe palma
de mallorca inter-zonal in prior to the
candidates matches so it was really
Bobby in his prime so really just
amazing stuff the first thing you will
see in the description below nobody I
would like to thank Frank combs
yo.hannes
froakie Johnson Eddie Frederick's son
Jake hitter and chess Atlas dotnet for
to my channel think you ought to really
appreciate it as usual you can check too
on my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Gibraltar
chess masters I'm pretty sure it was
called zebra Gibraltar trade wise
festival at some point but I guess they
change it they change everything to
masters these days so I'll continue
check up on your wonderful suggestions
and of course we are continuing the Paul
Morphy saga so thank you all I will see
soon and have an excellent rest of your
Monday